so I'm back in today I'm gonna answer a
question by a lady who called in and she
had a big confusion about diabetes she
was a diabetic type 2 and she watched
some of my videos but she was still
confused about the cause-and-effect
relationship she's on medication and I
have a lot of videos on this topic
but I'm gonna try to make it really
really simple so anyone could really
grasp it okay so today we're going to
talk about how to solve diabetes
overnight with just a simple
understanding of several links okay you
have the pancreas okay it's located
right here it makes a few hormones
it makes enzymes and then the hormone
that we're gonna talk about is insulin
insulin lowers the blood sugar okay so
it produces this insulin hormone goes
into the cell and then what happens it
once it lowers a blood sugar because
insulin is triggered by glucose or sugar
same thing what happens is it sends a
signal back turning the pancreas off
everything's cool everything works but
what happens if you keep consuming carbs
or sugar and it becomes more and more
your body considers it toxic okay so as
a way of protecting itself it starts to
resist the insulin okay so this is too
much sugar going in there's too much
insulin it's toxic
so that's called insulin resistance so
what happens is now we don't get the
feedback loops back to the pancreas
there's no return communication so the
pancreas to make this connect starts
producing more and more insulin to
create the same effect while this is
happening we have a lot of insulin and
we have insulin resistance
we still have normal blood sugar okay so
you check your blood and it's normal
because we have this resistance that's
buffering all this excess insulin
because if you didn't have that you
would have a massive hypoglycemic
reaction you have low blood sugar
because the insulin drives the sugar
lower so you have carbs increase insulin
and some resistance now over a period of
time maybe I don't know five to ten
years
your your pancreas gets tired it becomes
exhausted to the point where it's
overwhelmed so when it starts to burn
out we no longer have enough insulin so
now it's the instants gonna go down well
if you keep eating the sugar your blood
sugars are gonna start going higher
that's pre-diabetes and then even higher
diabetes okay so that's kind of the
mechanism and then we have medications
we have certain medications for diabetes
that increase or stimulate the cells to
make more insulin other medications that
help the receptor for insulin help to
receive it metformin for example and
then you have other diabetic medications
that basically cause the sugar to be
released through the urine so it just
dumps more sugar to help your body get
rid of it that way it's interesting this
medication actually puts your body into
ketosis interesting okay so that's
that's what medicine is trying to do
it's trying to treat things but it's
treating them lay down the chain of
events so what do we know we know that
the original problem is too much insulin
we know that carbs increase insulin and
we know the diabetic medication treats
the later effects of this chain reaction
so it basically treats the symptoms of
high insulin but why the high carbs why
are we consuming so many high carbs
well the dietitians are following the
Dietary Guidelines by the USDA and
they're recommending that 45 the 60% of
all of our calories should be in the
form of carbohydrates that comes out to
on average between 225 and 325 grams of
carbohydrate that is a massive massive
amount okay then we have guys like this
professor Tom Sanders head of diabetes
and nutrition science division in the
School of Medicine at King's College in
London
suti says diabetes increases risk of
cardiovascular disease
the diabetes is not caused by eating
sugar I think what happened was he was
sick the day they talked about insulin
this is right here why sugar sweetened
beverages contribute to obesity where
intakes are high it's probably because
it's providing extra calories okay he
doesn't understand insulin refocusing
dietary advice on sugar and away from
fat modification in reduction is not
helpful okay well what you need to know
about this guy is that he received four
point five million pounds for research
okay by the sugar industry okay and of
course dietitians are sponsored by the
food manufacturing companies and their
continuing educational programs okay so
that's why the high carbs so this is
what you need to know if you are a
diabetic how to solve diabetes overnight
is just to understand several simple
links okay excess carbs equal excess
insulin which equals insulin resistance
which then causes excess insulin until
the point where the pancreas becomes
burnt out
now the insta Goes Down and that causes
diabetes okay so what do you do about it
keto and I F you guessed it right I have
a link down below check it out if you're
new to my channel so if you want to get
notified with all my content click the
notification bell next to subscribed